which is lovely to have you here at
lending firm on comic-con today you've
had some quite dramatic moments yourself
having you as various students I mean
the old flaming sword behind we spoke to
Maisie Williams recently and she said it
there actually was flaming sword on set
yeah it wasn't CGI it was a I don't want
to give too much away but it was a
special set of swords that they made and
they set fire to them and a trip they
were lethal weapons I mean those things
were very hot and everybody kept out of
my way when I was swinging that thing
around it was pretty dangerous like oh
the badass in town with your flaming saw
the banner sometime with a good heart
yeah and what was it like battling
against the hounds well it was pretty
intense I mean that guy's he's about
twice my wit and nearly half as tall as
me again so all Rory McCann yeah it was
pretty it was exhausting we did the
fight over two days and the cave that
they made inside the studios so it was
probably one of the most exhausting bits
of acting I've ever had to do
he's an interesting character Burke
isn't he asleep Melisandre he's a
believer in the Lord of Light and why do
you think he's put his faith in someone
like Melisandre and what do you think
she's up to because she's an interesting
character that she has Marik is himself
well I'm a barek doesn't know that
berrak doesn't know that much about her
and of course he knows about the Lord of
Light and Thoris has basically taught
him and introduced him to the red God so
he said yeah I think he's basically he
sees there's so much so much horror and
injustice in the world you know so I
think someone who's a noble spirit is
just desperate to cling on to something
that is that is good and that is that it
that is you know something that is
beyond the kind of the wolves and you
know of man and in this world yeah it's
been some striking deaths throughout the
seasons I go into it I think you've had
your own death and a tree elevation
never knew what was that like going that
scene that was grim I mean it was very
gory I I was rigged with so much blood
like litres of blood so I don't know if
you can actually see it but whenever I
get cut down the shoulder it's like
there's fountains of blood come up so it
took hours to get all that that blood
off afterwards it was pretty messy yeah
if you had to go out and not come back
not reanimate if you had to have one of
those striking deaths how would you like
to meet your maker is Barrett I think
barracks should fight a dragon
fire with fire I just thought of that no
no that sounds good yeah
leaving sword it gets a flaming dragon
yeah honey you know a good shield he
could protect himself I think he'd be
pretty good yeah what about the
Brotherhood without banners what do you
think they'll get up to next well I
think they're doing a good job
protecting the weak and misfortunate but
if there is a war coming and it looks
like there is you know I think those
boys should be should be at the
forefront and either barrack or
authorial should be with the flaming
swords you know being the kind of fam
that the shock troops if you like yeah
what kind of qualities do you think you
have to have to make it to the end on
Game of Thrones do you think barrack has
the qualities that you need to survive
well as is kind of evident that it
doesn't really matter if you're a good
guy or a bad guy in this you know Death
Comes to anybody so you know he could be
the the best fighter in the world and
still get cut Don so I think it's just
the luck of the draw I think whatever
you know whether whether the pits are
smiling on you or not that's that really
decides it at the end of the books at
the end of TV - if you had to kind of
bet he would be one of the last men or
women standing who do you think will
still grieve oh I'd like Tyrion to be
there I think he's my favorite character
he's very funny as well yeah I'd like
I'd like him to master the end
a great character so what is it that you
particularly enjoy about how Tyrion is
on screen I think he's a good guy
ultimately you know you know there's
there's nobody really good
apart from Varrick but no I think he's a
I think he's a really strong strong guy
you know and I think you know and
despite his size and everything else I
think he's just I just think he's a he's
a great car he's also very funny
which is nice you know and you got kind
of dry wit which is great how do you
think you'd make out in barracks world
if you had to go back into Game of
Thrones time at me well I I trend at the
Rada three years with swords so I I
don't know what it's like in real life
using a sword and cutting people to bits
but I don't know I might last a few days
that's all you could hope for in that
world sometimes isn't it yeah absolutely
you'd be lucky if you lasted a couple of
seconds well is it like I think with
your co-stars on screens which even
people like Maisie Williams Joe
Dempsey's Gendry called Kayla Soros well
what those guys like well Paul's lovely
mean you know me and Paul just headed
off he said he's a lovely guy to be
around you know he's great fun and Suze
Rory we had a lot of laughs
but I'll never forget that fight where
we train for a month to do that fight
and we did it in two days but it was the
most grueling thing he could ever do I
mean there were literally people
standing with ice water we could only
fight for two minutes at a time because
we were overheating and there was steam
coming office and then they would we
would stagger right outside they enter
the fresh air and they were just DOS
this with freezing cold water so he
didn't know where he so that was and
incredibly grew also because I was
waving at the sword
any oxygen that I was trying to get in
the sword was the flames were sucking up
all the oxygen so it may look kind of
effortless but it was really hard work
I think you know when you can make
something look effortless that's great
acting and great work behind the scenes
because it does like effortless it looks
very very natural the whole shows like
that yeah
well I think barek as well he's one of
these fighters you know he doesn't he's
not a grunter or a shorter you know he's
incredibly like the samurai he say he
has the the calm you know and he doesn't
give much away because that's the real
warrior is a you know contained
what about behind-the-scenes moments it
would be surprising to find out for fans
how something works or how it is behind
the scenes on set typical day well
basically all my all my stuff was done
most of my stuff was done in that cave I
think people would be amazed at the the
heat that was in that cave it was like
we're talking nearly 50 degree heat
with full armor which weighs about three
stone and wet and fighting like as but I
think people would would you know they
probably think I would see actors you
know prancing around in tights but no
yeah you got to be pretty fit to do
those fight seats
you're pretty slim Vic I can see that
you mean he must have immunity did he
drop weight when you were doing that at
all yeah I did actually yeah I mean yeah
I put on about an extra half a stone
because I knew I was going to lose that
at least in those two days and I lost
about half for a three-quarters of stone
yeah even though he's eating tons you
know but the the Rory McConnell Talia
and it was fierce and you know you burn
a lot of energy when you're pushing
you're very hot what's it meant to being
part of Game of Thrones it's been
brilliant you know it's great to be part
of a kind of a legendary series and I'm
just surprised the amount of people who
stopped me and go are you buried I know
I'm Richard Armour but you know it's
it's it's great you know understate the
fans seem so lovely you know and they're
just genuinely they just love they love
the world and it's a brilliant world to
escape and and finally what would you
like to say to fans of the show who are
watching this video um I just say you
know keep watching and enjoy it and I
think there's a lot more surprises
coming up
you